check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
brothers and sisters who are watching
this welcome inshallah so this video i
really want you guys to pay attention
we're going to try to keep it on 30
minutes and we want to cover some
areas uh when it comes to consciousness
because it's
something i am i would like to
understand
more better because i don't usually use
it in my arguments when i'm having a
discussion with atheists
but like uh brothers like jake and uh
sharif
are people who have been in the field
for a long time who are doing amazing
work
um and really wanted to you know i
wanted to
give them my platform as well in the
context because i believe you know they
do brilliant work
and we're going to try to keep it you
know simple as much as possible
inshallah
but it's a very powerful argument for
those out there the muslim youth that
you can use if you're having a
discussion with your atheist friends
and in general there might be
non-muslims that's watching this
we can have an understanding because we
do have a story of a specific
atheist uh brother we'll say atheist
brother how is it how does
humanity anyways but he's a muslim now
so
the the question is and he had his own
youtube channel he was known in the
atheist circles
um and for him to accept islam via this
argument
i'm sure it's going to leave you guys
interested as much as me to find out
what what what did you guys start sharif
i think he was involved brother jake was
involved if i'm not mistaken
what is it that you convinced him of
that
he it was it was he changed his whole
you know perception about his worldview
so i want to start off
um i don't know it's up to you guys
where he won
but let's say let's go brother sharif
can go first
yeah yeah okay
when he was an atheist we went through
various arguments for the existence of
the creator
of spanish and he seems to acknowledge
that these are strong
good arguments but he couldn't let go of
materialism yeah so this idea that
everything
that exists is basically a product of
the physical material world
and so a few weeks ago uh we had
alhamdulillah we had hamza sauces on
other brothers
talking about materialism and more
specifically consciousness the hard
problem of consciousness
and then after the show which he did
watch we then had a follow-up discussion
with him
and he finally accepted this idea that
materialism
is not the fundamental thing that can
explain everything
including consciousness and so really it
was this discussion about consciousness
that opened his eyes to say that there
are
causes or things within the universe
that exists that cannot be explained
purely from a materialistic perspective
and this is what
many of the philosophers in science uh
say philosophers in
on the mind uh many neuroscientists they
call the hard problem of consciousness
which is basically
trying to explain why or how
materialism produces consciousness and
they say that
many of them say there's an unbridgeable
gap there's an
inability to bridge physical things
and the emergence of consciousness
within human beings
so that's okay that's brilliant so now
how would we like what what is in a
nutshell can someone explain
okay when we see materialism um can we
just give a
understanding of what exactly that is
what um
where is it used um etc and in what way
is it used
um so robert j can you explain to us
we've seen materialism
what exactly are we talking about you
know we're talking about materialistic
people i was talking about people
after money are we talking about
something else yeah yeah
no we're not talking about it in that
sense we're talking about it in
a philosophical world view sense so
materialism basically refers to
the idea that all that exists is just
matter and motion so
the physical stuff that we see atoms
molecules
that kind of thing they say that's all
that exists
the idea of things like god or angels
anything like that that doesn't exist
because they're not physical objects
so that's basically what materialism is
in a nutshell
okay um and and obviously like for
example a lot of scientists and the
scientific method of using our five
sentence
senses uh to come to conclusions by
scientific method so we're basically
saying that uh there is
more than our senses
so you know um um smell
touch here see taste
yeah so so these senses we're seeing
there is a different world
bigger than this in a nutshell right
right right and
and the materialists reject that and so
when we talk about
consciousness related to that we're
saying that consciousness
doesn't fit under materialism it's it's
something
else above that that can't be explained
by you know just
matter and motion scientists or
people in that atheist reject that
notion they believe everything is
materialistic
everything that okay so start sharif
let's get into it so tell us a bit about
consciousness you know um what do you
mean by it
break it down to us in child let's
understand when you say consciousness
what is it you know
um you know is it someone saying i'm a
conscious person is that what we're
talking about is it
you know it delve into a little bit more
inshallah yeah you know with your
consciousness of course you know yeah
yes it's not it's not too complicated
this discussion about consciousness
because we're all conscious so we all
have that experience and what is that
experience
it's the first person experience of the
world around us
it's the ability to be aware that we are
aware
yeah so you know it's not we're not just
a robot when you look at a robot
even a computer the computer's not aware
of its own existence it's not aware of
the experiences that it's having so it's
having the awareness of experience
and there's that's the first part of
consciousness the second part of
consciousness
is let's say jake's hat jake's hat is
red
yeah now we have a particular way of
experiencing
that hat that is not explained in any of
the physical components of the hat
so we look at the color red we can say
from a scientific materialistic point of
view
that it's the reflection of light at a
specific wavelength and a specific
energy yeah so these are the properties
of light
now everything that i described in the
properties of light
do not explain anything of the property
of the color red
yeah so redness of that hat is something
that emerges in our mind it's a
conscious experience
not something that comes from the
physical yeah another example just to
explain that point
is if you had a person who is blind from
birth and you
try to explain to them about photons or
particles or atoms you could probably
explain it to them
yeah you'd explain you know maybe the
mathematics of it
all of these things but i couldn't
explain
to a person who's been blind from birth
what the color red
looks like yeah what this experience is
it's
indescribable in that sense whereas
science looks at what is describable
in a third person objective way but
consciousness is a first person
conscious experience or subjective
experience it's what i experience
and what conscious people experience and
it's something that
comes about not because of the physical
properties within matter
so basically it's a personal experience
you know
like how it is for me to have for
example my mom always says you know when
it comes to
flavors and colors and choices these are
things that you can't argue with because
each person has its own you can't go to
someone and say no why don't you try
this food it's very nice and then
i tried i don't like it no why it's very
nice that's his experience
that he's had with that you know i come
from a kurdish turks background you know
let's talk about chicken donut kebab
why not you know if somebody if i say
chicken i don't like having chicken
donut at all
i say no actually i love it i have it
every day but it's a personal experience
how
it tastes to me my experience with it um
you know and that goes with everything
so you're saying each person has that
uh innate experience um with
everything around like even pain even
emotion even sadness
you know one person you know like
sometimes and this is very interesting
because
you know allah says in the quran that he
will not uh test us with things that we
cannot bear
and that's very interesting because that
changes from individual to individual
because if somebody like i've seen
people who have lost their children
yeah and i know some people if they lost
their children they might
psychologically could destroy them but
to some people it's like
you look at them and they're like like
wow like if that was me man if i was in
your position
i would i would be like i don't know how
i would have handed it
but you look at certain people and how
allah has created different people in
different ways
that their test to them is different to
yours what you
that you know what you might deem to be
you know really hard or whatever it may
be like
you can't bear another person you came
trying to say it's like allah's
criticism that
we have that inner consciousness in an
experience in different ways and we're
tested
via that as well i think maybe that
relates i'm not sure
um okay so um in a nutshell
we've got the idea behind that okay so
what
we understand what materialism was we
understood kind of
got a grasp of what uh consciousness is
self-awareness
um is um how did you guys okay introduce
it to this brother who was an atheist
what was
what was the first thing was he at first
apprehensive was he like you know what
how can you just give me a little
storyline maybe um how you guys go into
the discussion maybe
um and the the the objections that he
had and
how that was you know counted maybe
do you want to take that sharif or you
want me to take it go for it jk
if you miss any details on that sid yeah
so i mean
we had been talking to this brother we
presented him
other args uh arguments for god's
existence things like the kalam you know
contingency argument these different
things
um but then we presented to him uh this
sort of argument from consciousness and
how
it couldn't be explained by materialism
because he was a hardcore materialist he
was like you know if i can't touch this
i can't taste it
it's not real it doesn't exist so we
said well what about your conscious
experience
it can't be quantified you can't like
put it under a microscope
and so we started to talk to him about
this more and more
his initial reaction was to say well
it's
it's an emergent property of the brain
it sort of arises from the brain matter
but when we discuss this with him more
we said no it doesn't really work and we
can get into more details if you want
as to why it doesn't work but eventually
you saw well
it can't actually be explained by the
brain matter it doesn't make sense how
all of a sudden this conscious
experience just
emerges out of physical material
and after a couple weeks of discussing
this with him he realized that he
couldn't really explain
how you have consciousness on
materialism and so he
just abandoned materialism altogether
and accepted
that there are these other things like
consciousness uh that exists and the
reason why
this is important to take note of is
because
our understanding of god is not a
physical object it's not like you can
put god under a microscope
and so when you show that the
materialist well there are
other things even in your own experience
that you have
such as your conscious everyday
experience
then it sort of opens them up to the
idea
that other things like god and angels
and gin exist
that's interesting so i just wanted to
add as well because
this is really important because a lot
of people will say the automatic
response will be
because yeah but we can cut a person's
brain open and we can see the nerves and
the neurons and the brain chemistry
that's going on in there
but this is like when you have a
computer
and you you look at the program within
the computer and you see the ones and
zeros
now the ones and zeros don't tell us
anything about the experience
of what those ones and zeroes mean or
the information
you need a mind to decode that
information yeah
and the x the computer itself it's
operating on ones and zeros this binary
code system
it doesn't suddenly give itself
experience it doesn't suddenly
realize its own awareness it doesn't
have choices
exactly so it's like again yeah yeah
another example would be like morse code
dots and dashes now if you saw dots and
dashes but you didn't know
you didn't have information already in
your head how to decode the dots and
dashes
then it's just dots and dashes so you
need a mind to decode that
so it's in essence you need a mind to
understand
what's going on in the brain in order to
have the ability to say well this is why
this
particular neurons firing is resulting
in this particular thought
so you have to have a mind prior to
the brain doing it's you know the
neurons firing and the action potentials
and all these things that are going on
in the physical brain
and just as a final point regardless of
this is
you know and this is really i think hits
the nail on the head
when you come across a person whether
that's a person's child or mother
you don't turn around and think the
person's not conscious because you're
not physically sore what's going on in
the brain
you already made that conclusion that
they are conscious
so you're concluding upon something
that's not physically directly
observable
but you're concluding that they do have
it which is consciousness
in and of itself so if you can use that
same process of thought for
understanding other people are conscious
you can use the same process for
coming to the existence that the creator
exists as well
i i sometimes use the argument the love
you know i sometimes say you know
sometimes it comes across wrong you know
because if you're giving dawah
uh to a female you call him you show eat
love and it comes the wrong way like i
don't mean to show me love i mean like
can you show me
love like in a maturistic sense you know
yeah
the thing is they would like yeah no if
we plug some uh you know because you
know sometimes people say show me love
brother you know and it might come up
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about showing you know physically
showing me uh you know sometimes i had
to make it clear or some the person
opposite me gets the wrong idea you know
i'm like i don't mean to like that i
mean like you know can you show me like
physically
and they're like no if we put you know
these things in your brain and we i
don't know about that
you just show me waves i'm talking about
can you show me
oh look this is my love towards you or
my love towards my mother
you can't it's something you know so you
can see that you know
not all atheists but some of them they
have this you know double standards
um sadly you know they do have this
belief you know
uh into the unseen world you know the
consciousness or the emotions
uh but yeah okay so i'm just trying to i
just wanna i just want to add on to that
point because
you're right you're hitting on an
important point love
is a function of our conscious
experience
it's just one example of what we're
talking about
and where i mean like you're saying can
you open up a brain or
show on a scan like oh these are the
neurons in the brain
that are you know this set of neurons
for for is responsible for
me loving my wife and then these other
ones over here are
the ones that are responsible for me
loving my brother or my friend
we do we don't have anything like that
in in even in
current neuroscience today they can't
actually pin that down
so that's that's part of the issue even
that that's part of the issue and also
what's part of the issue is even if
let's say for example even if they say i
look oxytocin yeah
yeah this oxytocin is being released but
what's within
you know if i wanted to study oxytocin
yeah this this
chemical that's been released in the
brain i can study carbon hydrogen oxygen
what other elements that
uh it makes up the particular physical
structure
but none of those properties this is the
point none of those properties
have love within it that's not a
property that's not an attribute
that's the thing you have this missing
this is why they call it the hard
problem because you have this mysterious
property that arises
which can't be reduced to what it
physically is
everything else within nature within the
physical world we can reduce it down so
for example
even your your you know physical body
can be reduced down to genes and you can
say well if this gene codes for that
this gene codes for that particular you
know hand or an eye or whatever
but when it comes to neurons and the
properties
within the neurons and the properties
within the physical world
none of them contain this property of
what we call
consciousness and conscious experience
exactly and that leads on to our
question of the hard problem of
consciousness
and like you said before even if they
were to gather that information and be
like this this part of the brain is
responsible for love
the thing is you can never measure
intrinsically that like what that
person's love towards his wife or mother
is that something
that he personally knows the love and
the sacrifice he will do
for that person nobody can go and
measure that nobody come and say you
know this person's love
level of love it's it's there's this
measurement look this is what no nobody
can ask
it comes back to you know um you know
innate it's something that's innate
and going back to the hard problem of
consciousness here
um tell us a bit about that you know
what what is the hard problem of
consciousness you know where is this is
this where
um scientists and atheists are having a
tough time
tackling so much soul that um
you know there are there are genuine
atheists that are actually
um being convinced by this like you know
with this brother that we have who was
convinced by this argument
uh maybe this played with a little bit
about the hard problem of consciousness
yeah so i'll take that and then sharif
if i miss out on anything you can add it
um but it goes back to what we were
talking about like what
sharif was saying about the morse code
or with the computer the ones and zeros
is that you can explain even brain
function in terms of
input output but you can't explain
the experience of that so the hard
problem of consciousness
ha deals with what's called qualia or
this first person
subjective experience of what you were
talking about ali of
of basically you can explain maybe even
the
the input and output and sort of the
function in the brain
uh for love or these different emotions
but you can't explain the experience of
it
right so there's this added element that
is on top of
more than just the function and this is
what uh
an interesting problem because today we
talk about like art of artificial
intelligence and
can you know basically machines become
human minds and stuff like that
and the answer is no because there's an
in-principle problem or sort of
an unbridgeable gap between the simple
input and output and the experience of
it for example
our computers or phones whatever we're
on right now they're running on a
particular software and hardware
there's input and output ones and zeros
in the background
but the computer is not having an
experience like even if you program it
to
to say certain phrases no matter how
eloquent it is we don't attribute an
experience of that to the computer
yeah just certainly it's like me going
to my computer and saying
like i'm sorry i'm making you work too
hard and you know
yeah ali can you stop you know pressing
that button you know it's it's it's not
it's it's systematic you know it's
it's programming you know there's a
there's a really good example
uh i can't remember the philosophy i
mean it might be uh
uh sir john searle yeah yeah he talks
about the chinese room
yeah gives you an example so he said
you've got a person inside this room he
doesn't know any chinese
yeah then you've got chinese people
outside the room and they're writing him
chinese letters
notes that have meaning and they're
sending it inside the room
he doesn't know any chinese but what
he's got he's got a rule book
and in the rule book it says if you see
these symbols these letters chinese
letters you respond with these chinese
letters in response
and so he's sending the message out and
so the people outside the room
thinking oh you know this guy knows
chinese but what he's simply doing
is just doing input output he's seeing
the letters he doesn't comprehend
understand what the meaning of those
letters he's just saying if i see these
letters i respond with these set of
letters back
yeah so what he was explaining is this
is what ai does it's what computers do
computers don't fundamentally understand
the experience
or the knowledge of the information
they're just responding
in different ways and maybe even
complicated ways but they're not
experiencing the information
understanding it and then repeating it
back or responding with that particular
information
so this is why it's a it's a fundamental
it's an in-principle problem
david chalmers another uh philosophy
yeah and i want to re i want to read a
quote from him
actually if i could just a quick quote
because this term
hard problem of consciousness was put
forward by
david chalmers who was a philosopher and
he explains very nicely
what the hard problem is he says what
makes the hard problem hard
and almost unique is that it goes beyond
problems about the performance of
functions
to see this note that even when we have
explained the performance
of all the cognitive and behavioral
functions
in the vicinity of experience as
perceptual discrimination
categorization internal access verbal
report
there may still remain a further
unanswered question which is why
is the performance of these functions
accompanied by experience
and so that's what we're talking about
is with a computer
there's a performance of functions but
there's no experience
with us there is a performance of
functions
that is accompanied by an experience
it's not just love
it's what it's like to love your wife
what it's like to
love somebody else that what it's like
is the experience
rather than just merely the function and
that's what on materialism
you can't explain you can explain the
input output like a computer but you
can't explain the experience of it so
that's the hard problem
it certainly is a hard problem a big
problem for atheists there
a lot of atheists when when you explain
this to them the first reaction is
always to say no no no
we'll find out in the future how yeah
consciousness works
this is what they always say
what do you think about name the signs
of the gaps yeah
yeah yeah but the pro the problem here
ali is this
is that you can't science deals with
what is external
to the human being a third person
objective analysis
but this is a first person subjective
experience for example
i can see jake's hair and i see it's red
you see it as red
but do i see the same red as you to have
the same experience
i can't know that yeah we can say yeah
what we're seeing is red
but your experience of red will be maybe
different to my experience
and there's no way that science can tell
me whether we are experiencing it the
same way
so it's not so it's not just a problem
which is
in the future it's a problem where
there's an unbridgeable gap
science deals with what third person
objective analysis
exactly is consciousness is a first
person
yeah and you subjective see sorry go
ahead so you know there was this dress
that was going around in social media
and they were saying yeah
what color do you see i don't remember
yeah so some people are like oh
green sister and i was thinking that
these people are bugging out like i was
i was doubting them and they probably
doubted me yeah but it goes back to this
argument you know because i didn't they
that's what they were seeing you know uh
so it refutes the
refuse this whole materialistic uh
concept
even even if both people are seeing
green color dress
how do we know that the both of them are
seen green in the same way
yeah yeah sound steelers
yeah you can never measure that and
sharif you're right they go to this
oh well just because we don't know now
maybe we're going to find out in the
future with the advancement of science
and all this
and that's when i say well you get on
muslims and theists all the time for
this idea of faith
that sounds like you got more faith in
science bro know
it goes back to that someone's have a
discussion with certain atheists and
they say you know um they talk about
time you know if you give enough time
there is a chance this will happen
and we say well that's irrelevant to the
point because if i had a i'll give this
example all of the time yeah
it's like if you have a a bowl let me
i've had an empty bowl and i said
um you know if i gave it enough time
uh with a chocolate cheesecake with four
strawberries on top
appear um they would say yes um no
what we're saying well the properties to
make that is not in there
time is irrelevant to the point here and
i think it's the same here you know
the time is irrelevant we will in the
future
they don't i don't think they understand
the the problem that they face they
think
you give me enough time because they
always have this concept can enough time
the chances that will happen
chance of this will happen you know and
i think they use these arguments a lot
um the question not all
see this is the thing the ones who have
done the research in this subject
area they understand the problem so you
have some
some philosophers of the minds in your
sciences that believe consciousness
is an illusion doesn't really exist yes
that's one thing they're saying we don't
really have
this concept of experience then you have
others
who say that consciousness
is is existed in all things
yeah even in atoms and electrons and
rocks
they have a proton consciousness double
doubles experiment you know that was the
experiment
they have well yes that's yeah so so
even people
then you've got other people like donald
hoffman professor donald hoffman
who says no conscious matter is produced
by
consciousness and he gives examples like
the double
experiment and other things on the
quantum mechanics so he says this is
what they call idealism this idea that
consciousness produces material
because they're saying because it's an
unbridgeable gap between explaining
materialism
a rising consciousness and the same
consciousness is
more fundamental because it's what we
understand the world
with is consciousness so he's saying
consciousness is what produces
physical material out there for a lot of
people and by the way
that guy the guy whose quote i read
before professor david chalmers
he is a naturalist he's an atheist he's
not he's not a believer
but he's pointing out and he's being
honest like look this is a hard problem
for us guys so
there are some atheists out there who
are being honest about the problem
saying look we haven't solved it so far
and maybe they have some grand hope of
it later on but
i think more and more people are
starting to see that this is an
in-principle problem doesn't matter how
much time you have
you're not going to solve the problem
time is irrelevant yeah and i think if
atheists watching this you know
we want to make something clear because
you know one thing that i learned from
speakers corner one thing that i learned
from star homes resorts is
um you know is that we're not here to
win points over you guys if there's
atheists watching this we're not here to
be like
you know we got you guys yeah we've
cornered you our religion doesn't teach
that we're not here today we're
genuinely just trying to reason with you
guys
and make you guys understand us because
like the brother we had the discussion
with
he was honest enough to not only accept
it
but also accept islam and so i don't
want atheists to feel like you know be
defensive and we're trying to you know
mock them etc
what we're just genuinely trying to do
is show you guys why we believe
there is a logical answer that and the
the best possible answer to that is like
god exists and we're trying to break
that down by consciousness
and other things so i just want to make
that clear because i don't want you guys
to feel that you know we're trying to
you know that's not our aim our aim is
to you know learn from each other and
for you guys to understand our point of
view
uh why is consciousness not a problem
for islam so people that are watching
that they would say okay you know what
this is
it's a problem for all right let's say
our as atheists and material in the
material
you know materialistically you know
people who see that everything is
you know we cannot put up with our
senses what about islam isn't it a
problem for islam
go ahead sharif if you want to answer
okay so obviously from an islamic point
of views that we don't believe that
physical material things
which are non-conscious caused us to
have consciousness
we fundamentally believe that there is a
unlimited
independent creator a loss wa dalla who
is
all-knowing who has will who has
intentionality who is therefore what we
probably turn conscious who willfully
created human beings and therefore
willfully created us to have this
ability to have consciousness now how
that mechanism
of creation occurred we don't know that
allah knows that
but what we do have now is we have an
explanation of how
we have consciousness for a lot of
atheists under what they call pan
psychism which is where they say oh
mata has consciousness even the electron
has consciousness
they just assert it as a brute fact you
know something exists but there's no
explanation why it exists
don't ask why yeah exactly whereas we
say no something exists within human
mind which is consciousness
how do we explain that well there are
many arguments to the existence of allah
it's not just one
but when you go through these arguments
then you understand that what if allah
exists and he does exist then he's the
cause and creator of
all things yeah why does allah exist
because we say he's a necessary being
he's eternal independent
he doesn't require an explanation for
his own existence
but he allah explains everybody else's
existence
and the properties of those existence
including the properties of human beings
who have conscious awareness william
andre yep yeah and uh just to add on to
that sharif
also in islam we have this concept of
the
or the the soul the spirit whatever you
want to call it
we we don't only believe that for
example whether it be man
or angels or jinn or even allah himself
we don't believe that it's just material
objects and that's all that exists
so the reason why consciousness and this
is what the brother saw
is that on a materialist framework you
can't make sense of consciousness
but when you have this idea that the
creator himself who's the foundation
for everything that exists is not a
physical material object
okay then we can make sense of
everything else such as our conscious
experience
and all of these other things begin to
fall in place like the existence of
angels doesn't seem crazy and spooky
and gin and all this kind of stuff it
fits nicely in line
as far as the package and the the entire
islamic world view
we can see oh well that makes sense
consciousness isn't some weird thing
if we have a creator who himself is not
a
physical object and he's the foundation
for everything that exists
so once this is explained and once you
abandon materialism
then it kind of softens in in at least
in my experience with this particular
brother
it softened his heart it softened his
mind for him to start to consider islam
and to start consider these other
understandings
and alhamdulillah he embraced islam
in the end because that because of it
and this argument was a main
um function in that process
both of you guys it's absolutely amazing
i think we need to do more of these
where we break down
these concepts inshallah for the layman
to understand i think that was really
good i was very
that was amazing uh uh thank you both
you guys may allah bless you both for
you guys and shauna with the works that
you're doing
i'll learn a lot from brother jake i'll
definitely follow you from now on as
well inshallah
um and yeah promises if you've enjoyed
that if you want more please let us know
if you want specific topics for us to
discuss
uh we can do that free ramadan inshallah
we'll see if the brothers are free but
yeah so that was the argument from
consciousness and how it makes sense in
islam
um and yeah i hope you guys learned from
that inshallah till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh